digamos que queremos evaluar la integral
indefinida de x al cuadrado por 3 x 1 de
x pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta quizá estén pensando
en qué técnica sofisticada a usar para
resolver esto pero muchas veces verán
que la mejor técnica es la menos
sofisticada primero habrá que
simplificar esto algebraica mente en
este ejemplo qué pasa si distribuimos la
x cuadrada pues tendremos un polinomio
dentro de la integral esto será la
integral de x cuadrada x 3x que nos da 3
x cúbica y menos 1 por x cuadrada nos da
menos x cuadrada esto por de x el
resultado es algo bastante sencillo de
evaluar la anti derivada de x al cubo es
x a la cuarta entre 4 esto es 3 x x a la
cuarta entre 4 y la anti derivada de x
al cuadrado es x al cubo entre 3 menos x
al cubo entre 3 y como es una integral
indefinida es posible que tengamos una
constante aquí que escribimos así con
esto terminamos
importante aquí fue que con un poco de
álgebra simplificamos esto para obtener
una forma que es más directa para
evaluar la anti derivada hagamos otro
ejemplo digamos que tenemos la integral
indefinida de una expresión más
sofisticada x al cubo más 3 x x al
cuadrado menos 5 todo esto entre x al
cuadrado por de x pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta y de
nuevo quizás se vean tentados a aplicar
algún truco sofisticado para resolver
esto pero lo importante aquí es darse
cuenta de que primero pueden simplificar
esto algebraica mente qué sucede si
dividimos cada término entre x al
cuadrado esto va a ser igual a x al cubo
entre x al cuadrado nos queda x 3 x x al
cuadrado entre x al cuadrado nos da 3
solito y menos 5 entre x al cuadrado
podemos escribirlo como menos 5 por x a
la menos 2
aquí sólo tenemos que aplicar la inversa
de la regla de la potencia para
encontrar la anti derivada la anti
derivada de x es x al cuadrado entre 2
más la andi derivada de 3 es 3x la anti
derivada de menos 5x a la menos 2 vamos
a incrementar el exponente en 1 y lo
dividimos entre ese valor nos queda 5
por x a la menos 1 entre menos uno y
como tenemos menos entre menos nos queda
positivo más 5 por x menos 1 podemos
comprobar esto calculando la derivada y
así verificar que nos da este resultado
y por supuesto nunca debemos olvidar
sumar nuestra constante c cuando
resolvemos una integral indefinida
hagamos otro ejercicio más tenemos la
integral indefinida de la raíz cúbica de
x a la quinta de x pausa en el vídeo y
vean si pueden evaluar esto la idea es
reescribir todo esto para dejar un solo
exponente esto es igual a la integral
indefinida de x a la quinta
todo esto elevado a un tercio así es
como reescribimos la raíz koubbi
como la potencia un tercio por de x esto
es igual a la integral de x y si tenemos
una potencia elevada a otra potencia es
lo mismo que tener la multiplicación de
ambos exponentes lo que nos da x a las 5
tercios por de x muchos pudieron pasar
directamente a este resultado y
nuevamente aplicamos la inversa de la
regla de la potencia esto va a ser igual
a x ^ incrementamos este exponente en
una unidad tres tercios lo que nos da
ocho tercios y multiplicamos por el
recíproco de esto que es tres octavos
más para verificar lo aplicamos la regla
de la potencia multiplicamos ocho
tercios por tres octavos lo que nos da
un coeficiente de 1 y a esto le restamos
tres tercios o una unidad lo que nos da
cinco tercios que a su vez nos da lo que
teníamos originalmente la moraleja de
este vídeo es que muchas veces la
técnica de integración más poderosa es
la de simplificar primero algebraica
mente antes de integrar